first of all i mean this is you look
amazing i'm especially happy because you
match our ep colors
isn't great but who are you wearing and
you're rocking a little pink in your
hair tonight i know i know i just
thought you know i wanted to keep up a
little bit with the times but i like to
keep up on a grown-up basis i don't want
to i don't want to look like somebody
trying to an older woman trying to look
like a child i hate that i see it a lot
and i don't like it this is porn's a
school schooler
this isn't that belt
this is
uh as a dino liar
isn't that fun you're nailing the goal
you're hitting it oh my god i mean i'm
looking at you like i aspire you look
incredible thank you honoree tonight how
did it feel to get that call you would
be honored at this event which i cover
it every year and it's a very special
event the power of women
i'm astonished
i'm astonished but it's been a crazy
year for me it's as though i'm
everywhere doing everything and how does
that feel incr amazing but you know i
have a documentary that's premiering on
pbs october 5
and it's a terrific one you know it got
fabulous reviews but what's really great
which tickles me the most
rotten tomatoes gave it a hundred
that's the approval rotten tomatoes 100
a-plus plus well you know when you get
an honor like this and you have a
documentary i'm sure it kind of makes
you reflective what do you think about
what you want your legacy in this
industry to be because people look up to
you so if you look back at that what is
your legacy
i don't know that i can put out
information about my legacy i think
that's for other people to do really
but we can just say that
just the girl who decided to go for it
which happens to be the title of my
documentary but it it absolutely fits
that's why i saw it on a t-shirt and i
said that's me you're so inspiring rina
because i think women are often treated
like we have an expiration date in this
business
it is and you're here and what if you
were going to tell anybody you know
little girls who are watching this what
advice would you give them on continuing
their career going for it all the time
you know never stopping well i i would
just say stick to what you love
don't let anybody
tell you what you should be doing if
this is what you want to do be in the
show business
stick to it's hard
and nobody said it was going to be easy
but if you really love that do it don't
let anybody
change your mind simply because they
think they know better they don't you
know what you love and what you love you
will always do well
well of course i got to ask you about a
big circle you're making back to west
side story what can we expect and how
incredible is it to you that you're back
in it i am so excited i can't stand it
you're going to wet your knickers
how do you think these young ones did in
the rolls
fabulously i mean our maria was 17 when
she started the film like juliette in
romeo and juliet which this is based on
as you know
she had her 18th birthday during the
filming of the movie
and the all of the latino kids are
really latino
i mean imagine that i mean revolutionary
that didn't happen in the original
there's so many things that are
that have been
stephen
stephen spielberg and tony kushner
who wrote the who's the playwright who
wrote angels in america have made this
a new experience
without changing
i mean little changes but without
changing a lot they just did this
incredible
stephen
is
a bloody genius i was about to use a
very bad word
and you know what it is we would have
bleeped it for you i know but who wants
to be believed that's no fun so you
think the the fans of the original will
be satisfied
i would hope so
i you know i know that the fans are now
people my age or maybe not i love it not
as old as i
but uh
i mean i can't see anybody saying well
that's not how they did it before
that's right
this one improved this is a re-imagining
and i won't say improve because that
puts down the other one and we don't
want to do that because if we if that
didn't happen the first one this would
not be happening another industry legend
betty white turning 100 next year
why not why not what do you have to say
to betty on her 100th birthday
betty
you are my hero
you just knocked me out i hope you still
remember that when we attended an
opening once
the music was so loud we couldn't bear
it and you said i have an idea
let's fall on the floor and start
screaming this is true she says let's
start screaming our head up we'll get
attention then and they'll stop the
music just to see what's happening so we
did she says you go first
so
i lay down on the ground people all
around us with drinks in their hands
and then she joined me and was
just screaming
like that
and nobody nobody i mean people were
like this
anyway talking i mean nobody gave one
damn you know what rita to all those
people who didn't give a damn you're
being honored here she said but she said
to me so much for fame
so much for faith
i love her any other advice you'd give
women tonight women who have to deal
with so much from men in this industry
maybe from men in their personal lives
and to just keep going and keep striving
for what they want well i think they
really have to uh
lots of wonderful things are happening
are in the throes of happening for women
and i think what that's done it's
encouraged the young women
that's what's so fabulous
and i think it's only going to get
better
i think it's only going to get better
and stick to your guns if this is what
you want or this is what you want to say
do it
do it you have no obligation to anyone
but yourself
[Music]